all right let's go to Jack in Texas hey
Jack welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
howdy sir thanks for your time
sure what's up I'm looking at buying a
house cash here in a couple of years and
I was just curious as I've started to
talk to other people about it they've
all started just not doing that
taking the down taking the money you'd
spend on it and you know throw at other
investments that'll make you more money
and I just kind of want to get your
thoughts on why you would suggest buying
a house cash or if you wouldn't what you
would put it in curious to get your
thoughts on why you would take financial
advice from a bunch of broke people
that's hey listen if you can figure out
what fat people are doing and not do it
you probably will be skinny so let's uh
let's think it's through for a minute
okay the data tells was hard data not
just theory we've done that we did the
largest study of millionaires ever done
in North America ten thousand one
hundred and sixty seven of them were
surveyed
it's the largest study ever done not
your broke friends but real millionaires
real millionaires people have a million
dollar net worth or greater chris hogan
did the book off of it called everyday
millionaires it's full of stories and a
hundred and forty statistics of the
millionaires and so if you want to be a
millionaire what they have to say as a
group ten thousand of them the data from
that is important would you agree with
that yes there and that's it's more
important than what Dave Ramsey says by
the way because I'm just a bald guy with
an opinion but when you talk to a lot of
people that do one thing and do it well
and you can extract from that data
points that are consistently showing up
like in excess of fifty or sixty percent
of the time you have statistical
evidence at that point that's what a
research project is for and so that's
why we did it because we wanted to know
if my opinions that I've been teaching
all these years and what I believe to be
true and how I've lived my life and it
worked for me actually worked across a
series of real millionaires and what we
found was not fifty percent not sixty
percent
but north of 80% of the millionaires
that's like statistically almost all of
them you know I mean you look at a
political poll if they get 51% on
something they they call it a touchdown
you know but I'm talking 80 85 percent
here's the thing we found 85 percent of
them said that they paid off their homes
very quickly and the average was ten
point two years so a paid off home
is a big indicator towards becoming or
being wealthy the second thing we found
was 93% of them systematically invested
consistently into retirement plans into
good mutual funds the paid off home and
the consistent investing in a 401 K Roth
IRA those kinds of things is what caused
people to be wealthy
so that is the actual truth that the
data backs up so having said that what I
have said all these years was backed up
and it was that your your turns out your
income is your most powerful wealth
building tool and when you don't have
any payments no house payment no car
payment no master card no student loan
that's been around so long you think
it's a pet when you don't have any
payments you have money and you get to
become very wealthy fast so at your
young age Jack if you can pay up pay
cash for your house you will be very
wise let me tell you how many of the
millionaires that we interviewed that
said what you should do is borrow as
much as you can on your house and invest
that money because you can make more
investing than you can then you would
pay out an interest let me tell you how
many of them out of 10,000 said that
zero that's statistically significant
zero not one said you ought to buy real
estate pay cash for it and or buy real
estate and borrow as much as you can on
it instead of using your money to buy
the real estate for cash instead of
doing that put the money in an
investment and just keep your real
estate mortgage your whole life because
investing is always better than a
mortgage it then paid off house exactly
zero
percent said that not a single one out
of 10,000 167 suggested that your broke
friends were on track so that's why
that's why I say that is because the
evidence is here have 30 years of me
doing this and the evidence of talking
to real millionaires and these
millionaires we're not just in our tribe
50 percent of them are in white space
meaning they could not spell Dave Ramsey
they didn't know who I was
these are just millionaires it's just
simple and they just borrow money no
they look at you like a German Shepherd
turn the head sideways woo what mm-hmm
you know and no borrow money mm-hmm no
here oh by the way for the rest of you
hold on I'm gonna give you a copy of
that book Jack every day millionaires
because you're gonna be one and you are
on your way man if you just if you just
go with your instincts because you have
good instincts and go with that stuff
instead of this other garbage
hold on Kelly I'll pick up and we'll
give you one of those you guys know what
percentage of millionaires inherited
enough money to become a millionaire
less than nine percent ninety-one
percent did not inherit enough money to
become a millionaire of the millionaires
we talked to oh the only way to be
wealthy is inherited in America today so
the wealth must be punished because I
have a political agenda yeah well the
problem is you don't have data and so
you're living in the land of Mythology
the truth is that out of 11 million
millionaires in America today somewhere
north of 10 million of them started with
nothing did not inherit anything or if
they did it was not enough to be of help
they might have inherited $5,000 or
$10,000 seventy nine percent of the ones
we interviewed inherited zero and the
rest of them not enough to help it was
just kind of a tip of the hat when
granny died I got 63 hundred bucks or
something that's an inheritance but it
didn't exactly make you a millionaire so
where does wealth comes from comes from
you controlling the person in your
mirror you're the problem and you're the
solution